we welcome you to cbs this morning and
unfortunately the news is not something
we can laugh about because of course
we're beginning in florida again today
where officials have now promised
to convene a grand jury to investigate
that devastating building collapse
search and rescue efforts are now in
their seventh day
and it's agonizing work and agonizing is
the word here
another body was recovered last night
now that brings the detail up to 12.
149 people are still missing the former
surf side building inspector who said
the tower was in
very good shape in 2018 has been put on
leave from his current job
manuela jorquez joins us from surfside
well good morning
where is the rescue operation now
good morning the work is nonstop despite
all the dangers including this
rescue crews believe a part of the
debris pile may
actually be supporting that part of the
building right there which remains
standing
but in danger of collapse still they say
they are focused on job number one
and that is trying to reach any possible
survivors
the search and rescue continues amid the
shattered remains of the champlain south
tower with leaders insisting this
is not yet a recovery operation nobody
is giving up hope here
nobody's stopping the work goes on
full force rescue crews have moved
around 3 million pounds of concrete
while they clear debris
the investigation into the collapse is
still in its early stages
i know what the video showed but it's
what was going on
in the structure before it fell down
that you don't see in that video
alan kilzheimer is a structural engineer
hired by the town of surfside to find
out what went wrong
he has decades of experience
investigating disasters
like the 9 11 terrorist attack on the
pentagon
and he's looking at everything from
witness interviews to reports of cracked
concrete under the building
how much weight should be put on those
findings
i wouldn't put any weight on them at
this point in time it could have been a
number of things that
alone wouldn't have caused the problem
but together with the trigger caused the
problem
one witness account in particular caught
his attention the testimony of a lobby
attendant who heard
something the night of the collapse he
heard a muffled
boom and then x number of seconds later
a much bigger boom and then y seconds
after that
a much bigger boom so there were three
booms
i think i understand the second one i
think i understand the third one i don't
understand the first one
this is a puzzle and and we have to
figure out
how to put all the pieces together
in the meantime miami-dade county
conducted an audit
of similar buildings and according to
the new york times they found
41 structures that were past due on the
required 40-year
inspections 24 of those buildings were
labeled to be technically
unsafe structures because they were past
due but
officials did say they also did not find
any
major structural concerns
it's an important review there manny
thank you very much